This is tagged to take one mark.
Alright gang.
Here we go.
The Big Bang theory is the most popular show on television.
It centers on four male friends who were characterized by essentially every
Hollywood stereotype about geeks and nerds and exist to us.
All right,
just a few more feet and here we are gentlemen,
the gates of L's hubbub.
Good Lord,
don't panic.
This is what the last 97 hours of been about.
Leonard,
Sheldon,
Howard and Raj on lack most of the traits traditionally associated with leading
men in Hollywood.
They're not conventionally handsome,
they're not confident and they're definitely not athletic.
What they are are Dorky,
insecure fan boys who are plagued with a wide variety of anxieties,
illnesses and awkward personality quirks.
They also happen to be the perfect embodiment of the media trope,
which I call the adorkable,
misogynist,
adorkable misogynists or male characters whose geeky version of masculinity is
framed as both comically pathetic and endearing.
Wait,
what's on top of that?
Wireless web cams,
white pillow,
and it's their status as nerdy nice guys.
That then lets them off the hook for a wide range of creepy entitled and
downright sexist behaviors you may want to put on slacks.
Now in order to help explain how this convention works,
we will need to take a quick trip back in time to the 1980s
the year was 1984 gs and one of the most popular summer movies was a film called
revenge of the nerds.
No,
he's worth the first socially awkward nerds to grace the big screen,
but they did help popularize this type of character over the next few years.
This geeky guy archetype quickly gained traction in Hollywood.
How's it gone?
And by the 1990s it had become something of a mainstay in comedy entertainment.
It's worth noting that this type of character is nearly always white.
Though there are a few rare exceptions,
the Hollywood nerd is almost always positioned in opposition to the expected
norms of macho man.
This is usually accomplished through the juxtaposition with the jock archetype
when contrasted with hyper masculine guys who perform a crude aggressive form of
manhood are geeky.
Hero gets to be framed as the better,
smarter,
more sensitive,
the alternative.
He's the misunderstood.
Nice Guy,
I,
Betty,
I'm not kissing a nurse who was unfairly bullied and mock the by his peers.
Not every guy's born with blonde hair and a chin.
You could crack walnuts with catch babies.
I had to use my imagination.
He's presented as the clear underdog in the manhood competition
that another way of saying,
I'm out of this world.
I love the excitement right
chasing you.
It's a good time to ask you about the dance
on closer inspection.
However,
we start to notice that these types of characters are shown engaging in a
variety of harassing,
entitled and Sexist Behavior where women are concerned they consistently stock
spy on lie too and try to manipulate the women in their lives.
They're overbearing.
They refused to take no for an answer and they often ignore the basic tenants of
consent.
Hey,
most of this behavior falls under the rubric of sexual harassment and
occasionally it escalates to the level of sexual assault.
Both revenge of the nerds and 16 candles includes scenes in which Geeky,
nice guys commit acts of rape.
This type of behavior should be understood as reprehensible,
I say should be,
because that's not how these TV shows and movies frame it.
All right.
You guys ready?
Wait,
huh?
Instead,
this behavior is framed as kind of pathetic.
I don't know what you're doing here,
away,
but ultimately harmless.
How's this look?
And even endearing in an adorkable sort of way.
Your Dad nerd.
Yeah.
Do you?
Thanks.
And it's the adorkable part of the adorkable misogynist that makes this trope so
insidious.
So let's return to the Big Bang theory.
We have to get rid of the time machine.
The four geeky friends on this show are written to be genuinely likable.
Guys,
they're even capable of fleeting moments of heartfelt sensitivity,
thoughtfulness,
and sweetness.
What is it?
It's a snowflake from the North Pole.
Are you serious?
It'll last forever.
I preserved it.
And the 1% solution of polyvinyl ass little resin.
This nonthreatening adorkable framing is designed to excuse the other more toxic
part of the Tro,
the four leading men on Big Bang theory.
Each present their own distinct flavor of adorkable misogyny.
Howard is the creepy pervert with a heart of gold tone to cover it.
You unkosher delight.
I'm not necessarily talking to the food.
Did you have opened the door if he knew it was me?
Not since I found out.
The teddy bear you gave me had a Webcam in it.
Two route.
The first several seasons.
He's depicted as a want to be pickup artist.
Yes.
We're here to fix the cable.
He stocks harasses objectifies and tries to trick dozens of women into sleeping
with him.
How word talks about women the way a zookeeper might talk about trapping and
taming wild animals.
See,
first we let the lawyers and the jocks thin the herd and then we go after the
week and the old and the lane.
He's conniving.
He's manipulative and his behavior sometimes crosses the line into criminal
activity.
There's the house.
I found America's top models
built on the roof on I ECM.
Just LR sunbathing European style.
You can recognize people on Google Earth.
Of course not.
I got a buddy of mine at norad to have a spy drone flyover.
I should note that once Howard is in a committed long term relationship,
the way that his male chauvinism is expressed does shifts slightly.
So we stopped trying to be a womanizer,
but he still demands to be taken care of.
Okay,
and he refuses to share any of the domestic responsibilities.
Kind of hard to get your game and how many cleaner cleaning up.
Look at the mess the joker made of Gotham city.
I want this to feel like my house to,
oh honey,
of course it's your house.
That was,
why else would you be cleaning it all the time?
Raj is the sensitive guy turned inappropriate crump.
Okay.
He's the show's token geek of color and is endlessly mocked for being the most
feminine of the four friends.
I'm sorry,
what was your name again?
Raj is also the most socially awkward around women in the first few seasons.
He can't speak to women at all.
That's just fascinating.
Thank you.
Except when he's drunk or on drugs,
would you like to hear more about it?
In my hot tub,
and it's in those uninhibited moments when we see some very extreme levels of
underlying [inaudible] come to the forefront.
I'm very comfortable here.
Penny.
Joe,
why don't you shoot another silver bullet?
Okay.
Where are you going?
We're doing so low.
Even got to see my penis.
Leonard is the nice guy enabling.
He plays the more down to earth normal.
One of the group still.
He participates in much of the same behavior as his cohorts.
Just to a lesser degree.
Leonard's character arc is basically the pathetic nice guy who refuses to take
no for an answer and who eventually gets the girl.
How did you get her to go out with you?
Well,
she moved in across the hall.
They started to slowly wear me down
like a river carves,
a canyon.
One of the roles that Leonard plays on the show is as the guy who excuses and
enables the sexism of his male friends and you know that deep down inside
Howard's a really nice guy
cut the crap.
You set this up in you?
Yes.
She's a hooker.
Isn't chain a prostitute?
Yes.
You already gave her the money.
He might roll his eyes at his friend's antics,
but he never seriously challenges their behavior,
but I'd like to get lost.
Awesome.
Herb.
You don't triangle.
It's not helpful then I won't say I'd like to cover three quarters of her
surface area
and his mild protests work as a springboard for still more sexist jokes.
Not yet.
This is fun.
I know
Sheldon is the innocent bigot.
Most of the guys display a general disdain for icky girl stuff,
but Sheldon is the one who harbors the most virile inform of casual misogyny.
Tonight's theme flags of countries that have been torn apart and the women.
I have a feeling we're responsible.
My father used to say that a woman is like an egg salad sandwich on a warm Texas
hello
zone.
Only appealing for a short time.
The whole shtick is Sheldon's character is that he's too smart to understand or
care to understand what's socially appropriate and what's not.
As such,
he's dismissive of nearly everyone and their feelings,
but when he belittles and devalues women,
it's very specifically because they are women.
Thanks to you.
I know better than to ask if you're menstruating
and based on your behavior.
I don't have to.
Oh,
you hear women say is,
I'll just have a salad.
Where's my lip gloss?
I think this element should be called radium.
Okay.
That last one was madame Curie.
You what?
She was kind of an honorary man.
She had a penis,
made a science.
So how does the Big Bang theory keep us as the audience,
sympathetic to men who behave in such a reprehensible ways?
Action.
Well,
it's done by leaning heavily on a combination of ironic humor and a popular
writers trick known as lamp shading.
Most of the jokes on the Big Bang theory such as they are revolve around the
following ironic hook.
Since geeky guys don't fit into the macho mold of what we expect sexism or male
entitlement to look like.
It's funny to watch them engaging in that type of behavior.
It's anything good happened Thursday,
let's hit the clubs and meet hot women.
Do we go lock up?
Your daughters were gonna hit it and quit it.
Notice the target of the joke is not the misogynist behavior.
Or we could finish eating and go to the comic book store.
Hold sweat,
good plan.
Instead,
it's making fun of men who are not traditionally masculine enough to believably
pull it off,
smell bad.
It's a smell of new comic books.
Unlike many of our earlier examples from the 1980s the creepy behavior on the
Big Bang theory is meant to be understood for what it is.
I know you think you're some sort of smooth talking ladies,
man,
but the truth is you are just pathetic and creepy and this is where ironic
lampshade shading comes in.
So what are you saying?
Which is when media makers deliberately call attention to a dissonant or overly
cliched aspect of their own production rather than writing better,
different punchlines writers attempt to duck any potential criticism by pointing
out the sexism inherent in their own jokes themselves.
Well,
it that's it.
Confirm we now have the address of the top model.
Okay.
For the record,
what do you guys are doing is really creepy.
You know what?
If it's creepy to use the internet,
military satellites and robot aircraft to find a house full of gorgeous young
models so that I can drop in on them unexpectedly,
then fine.
I'm creepy.
This technique of making something super obvious to viewers is meant to let us
know that the writers are self aware and to make us feel like we're all in on
the joke.
Most comedy writers know that Retro Grade Style bigotry is no longer acceptable
on prime time television,
but many of them still want to use sexist,
racist,
and homophobic jokes as an easy way to get cheap.
Actually any monopolies just like regular,
except the money's in rupees.
Instead of hotels,
you build call centers and when you pick a chance card,
you might die of dysentery.
Ironic lamb shading provides a clever way for them to keep getting away with it.
It just Fyi,
that was racist
problem with this comedic device.
Is that by itself?
Hey,
I'm in judge.
Your phone support seems a bit racist.
He doesn't critique or challenge sexism,
homophobia,
or racism.
It's simply acknowledges it in a humorous way.
Very clever,
but still racist.
Duly noted,
Steve,
from Wichita.
Acknowledging bigotry is not the same thing as critiquing bigotry,
especially when the punchlines end up making light of serious social issues like
sexual harassment.
That to Cooper,
you said things to your employee that you just cannot say in the workflows.
Oh,
I see the confusion here.
Alex thought I was singling her out.
No,
I met that all women are
urgent.
You know,
even you.
No.
So while it's true,
the message of the Big Bang theory isn't sexism is super cool or lacks.
No one's going to be looking at her hair.
I'd argue the implications are much more troubling because the show is message
is more akin to sexism is mostly harmless and especially when that sexism is
coming from Geeky guys.
There are pitfalls.
Trust me,
I know when it comes to sexual harassment law,
I'm a bit of a self taught expert.
Misogyny is presented as just another socially awkward personality quirk as
something that's perhaps deserving of an eye roll or an exasperated look or
maybe some lighthearted chiding,
but never as something to be taken seriously or seriously challenged.
Wow.
Okay.
You're engaged to my friend,
Bernadette doesn't mine where I get my motor running.
As long as I parked in the garage,
I can't believe you're engaged to my friend and it's core workable.
Misogynists trope is built around the old axiom that boys will be boys.
Yeah,
and what that phrase really means is boys will be sexist or boys will be creepy
stalkers who sexually harassed women as the case may be.
On the very rare occasions when one of the Geeks is called out for his sexism.
The audience has meant to feel bad for him because his feelings got hurt on
television,
men's feelings and bruised egos are nearly always depicted as more important
than women's comfort for women's safety.
Look,
Howard,
I just want to apologize.
Be adorkable misogyny of the four main characters on the Big Bang theory is
tolerated.
It's tolerated by their peers,
by their girlfriends and by their employers.
Well,
despite your quirks that three of you are very accomplished in your respective
fields.
No what mean by quirks.
The trope downplays the sexism of men who don't fit into the macho stereotype.
My framing it as pathetic,
as nonthreatening and is not that big of a deal.
Of course,
the reality is that sexism is a big deal as practically any women involved in
Geek subcultures will tell you,
everybody was staring at me.
There is sadly no shortage of real life.
Examples of men involved in nerdy hobbies or professions who behave exactly like
the guys on the Big Bang theory and it's not harmless and it's not adorkable
sexual harassment scandals and had been sweeping through silicon valley.
That's 60% of women who work in the tech industry have reported on wanted sexual
advances as in it's simplest form.
It's a Toric,
the tax against women,
a frequent problem inside Uber,
sexual harassment and sexism she described and it's harmful in all the ways the
Big Bang theory tells us it's not.
It's damaging to women.
It's damaging to their sense of safety to their wellbeing into their careers.
Former Google engineer who wrote a 10 page memo criticizing the company's
diversity programs saying women lag behind in the tech world because of their
biology.
The unnamed Google engineering employee wrote biological causes may explain why
we don't see equal representation.
Men have a higher drive for status and women on average have more neuroticism.
If we added a laugh track to that clip,
it would be indistinguishable from the casual sexism that we can see on
practically any episode of the Big Bang Theory.
Trouble isn't with me penny,
it's with your gender and Sunday.
Scientists will discover at second x chromosome contains nothing but nonsense
and twaddle
and how difficult it is to do when she's bloated,
cranky and crampy.
Just because the performance of a geeky version of masculinity is markedly
different from traditional Hollywood archetypes.
That doesn't necessarily mean that eeky guys are any less invested in sexism.
The bottom line here is that there's nothing cute or harmless about misogyny
even when it's coming from men who may play Cleon boggle time.
It's really not that difficult to write nerdy male characters who aren't total
creeps.
There's our bed from the show community you have to understand about avid.
He's usually,
you know,
adorable.
We're like more for more.
There's line old from dear white people,
the TV series and there's Ben from parks and rec presenting.
The cones have done Shyer,
a brand new gaming experience.
All these characters somehow managed to perform a quirky,
awkward and often humorous form of masculinity without the undercurrent of
retrograde sexism.
It's long past time for Hollywood writers to retire.
The adorkable misogynists trope wants and for all.
Thanks for,
if you'd like to see more long form video essays that deal with the
intersections of politics,
masculinity,
and media,
then you can go over to Patrion and help fund the project there.
There's also a link to paypal in the description below.
I'll see you all next month with another video about Big Bang theory this time
about dicky masculinity.
Okay.